This is episode four of Not Built For This, Unbuilding the Terrace. Lake Charles, Louisiana is a low-lying city in the southwest corner of a low-lying state. It's right off I-10, about halfway between Baton Rouge and Houston. And when I first pulled into town, the city was bigger than I was expecting. It was nighttime and from a distance the skyline was lit up like some giant metropolis. It's like a gleaming city. If you looked quickly you might think you were looking at Manhattan. But when you get a little closer you realize those aren't skyscrapers lighting up the
这里是《不适于此：拆解特拉丝》第四集。路易斯安那州查尔斯湖是一座低洼城市，位于一个低洼州的西南角。它紧邻10号州际公路，大约在巴吞鲁日和休斯顿的中途。当我第一次开车进入这座城市时，它比我预期的要大。那是夜晚，远处的天际线灯火辉煌，就像某个巨大的大都会。它就像一座闪闪发光的城市。如果你匆匆瞥一眼，你可能会以为自己看到了曼哈顿。但当你走近一点，你就会意识到那些并不是照亮夜空的摩天大楼。
night. It's just nothing but fossil fuel infrastructure. It's just a series of refineries with lights all up and down the spires of these smok stacks. It's pretty dramatic. Lake Charles is a city built among petrochemical plants. It's sometimes hard to tell where a neighborhood ends and a refinery begins. Oil and gas companies are some of the largest employers in town. But you don't have to work in the industry
这里全都是化石燃料基础设施。这里只是一连串的炼油厂，这些烟囱的塔尖上上下下都亮着灯。这相当壮观。查尔斯湖是一座建在石化厂中间的城市。有时很难分清居民区在哪里结束，炼油厂又在哪里开始。石油和天然气公司是镇上最大的几个雇主。但你不需要在这个行业工作
to feel its effects. The spills and the fires and the high cancer rates. A lot of the gas that comes through this city gets exported and burned overseas. But the impacts on the climate are felt right back here in southwest Louisiana. Lake Charles is trying to recover from back-to-back hurricanes. In recent years, Lake Charles has been hit with more big storms than just about any city in the country. Well, here's a moniker no one wants,
也能感受到它的影响。泄漏、火灾以及高癌症发病率。流经这座城市的许多天然气都被出口并在海外燃烧。但对气候的影响却直接在这个西南路易斯安那州本土感受到。查尔斯湖正试图从连续不断的飓风中恢复过来。近年来，查尔斯湖遭受的大风暴袭击比全国几乎任何城市都多。好吧，这里有一个没有人想要的称号，
America's most weather-battered city. Yet, it belongs to Lake Charles, Louisiana. Even though we know intellectually that the burning of fossil fuels is making the weather more dangerous, it can be hard to really see that connection in our day-to-day lives. But you can't miss it in Lake Charles.
美国遭受天气打击最严重的城市。然而，它属于路易斯安那州的查尔斯湖。尽管我们从理智上知道，化石燃料的燃烧正在使天气变得更加危险，但在我们的日常生活中，很难真正看到这种联系。但在查尔斯湖，你绝对不会错过它。
The causes and the effects of climate change are on full display. When I visited, the tallest skyscraper downtown was completely abandoned, windows blown out by a hurricane. And in the distance, you could see that ominous petrochemical skyline with smoke trailing into the sky. Of all the storm-battered neighborhoods in this storm-battered city,
气候变化的原因和影响在这里展露无遗。我访问时，市中心最高的摩天大楼已经被完全废弃，窗户被飓风吹碎。而在远处，你可以看到那个不祥的石化天际线，浓烟拖向天空。在这座饱受风暴蹂躏的城市的所有饱受风暴蹂躏的社区中，
there's one in particular that I'm here to see. It's called Greenwich Terrace. It's a mostly black neighborhood, with wide suburban streets and modest single-story homes. So I'm here in Greenwich Terrace and I'm standing under a tree. I try to keep cool. I huddled in the shade of a tree and watched as a tiny bulldozer chomped away at some concrete. This is a sound of a bobcat that is tearing up what's left of the house.
有一个地方我特别要来看看。它叫做格林威治特拉丝（Greenwich Terrace）。这是一个主要是黑人的社区，有着宽阔的郊区街道和简朴的单层住宅。所以我在格林威治特拉丝，我正站在一棵树下。我尽量保持凉爽。我缩在一棵树的阴凉处，看着一台小型推土机大口大口地啃掉一些混凝土。这是山猫推土机撕裂房屋残余部分的声音。
All around me were the footprints of homes that no longer exist, with brakes in the sidewalk where the driveways used to be. Yeah, just a lot of empty, empty land. These houses weren't ripped up to make way for some big infrastructure project or a new development. The terrace has flooded so many times in recent years that the government decided to do something dramatic.
在我周围，到处都是不复存在的房屋的地基，人行道上还有车道曾经存在过的断裂处。是的，只有大量空荡荡的土地。这些房屋被拆毁并不是为了给某个大型基础设施项目或新开发项目让路。近年来，特拉丝已经淹水太多次，以至于政府决定采取戏剧性的行动。
They decided to tear down the houses and pay people to move to higher ground. Here is a sign that says, State Buyout Program, Greenwich Terrace Neighborhood, demolitions underway. Throughout the country, thousands of people are living in locations that regularly flood. And will only get more flood prone as the climate continues to change. Many of the people who live in these danger zones are caught in this demoralizing loop, flooding and rebuilding over and over again, and praying each time that the pattern doesn't
他们决定拆除房屋并付钱让人搬到地势较高的地方。这里有一个牌子，上面写着：州购回计划，格林威治特拉丝社区，正在进行拆迁。在全国各地，数以千计的人住在经常被淹没的地方。随着气候继续变化，这些地方发生洪涝的倾向只会越来越严重。许多住在这些危险地带的人陷入了这个令人沮丧的循环中，一遍又一遍地淹水和重建，每次都在祈祷这种模式不会
repeat. But in places like the Greenwich Terrace, the government is trying to break that cycle. They're giving up on the idea of rebuilding altogether, and instead trying to help residents move out of harm's way. It sounds simple on paper, but in practice it's often messy and painful. And so today, we're going to follow the process of unbuilding a flood-prone neighborhood through the eyes of one resident. We'll see what it's like to watch the place that you live become unlivable,
重演。但在像格林威治特拉丝这样的地方，政府正试图打破这个循环。他们完全放弃了重建的想法，转而试图帮助居民搬离危险地带。这在纸面上听起来很简单，但在实践中往往是混乱而痛苦的。所以今天，我们将通过一位居民的视角，跟随拆除一个易受洪水影响的社区的过程。我们将看看看着你居住的地方变得不宜居住是什么感觉，
to fight like hell for some help. But when help shows up, it comes in the form of an offer to leave the place you love. Because the Greenwich Terrace was just not built for this. I'm Emmett Fitzgerald. I'm standing in my old driveway. I'm standing in your old driveway? This is it? This is my driveway.
为寻求一些帮助而拼命抗争。但当帮助出现时，它却是一份离开你所爱之地的提议。因为格林威治特拉丝根本不适合这样。我是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）。我正站在我以前的车道上。我站在你以前的车道上？就是这个？这就是我的车道。
I'm here for your old driveway. This is it. This is my driveway Here for 20 plus two years I'm standing with Tramica Rankins on the empty plot of land where her house used to be The only thing left from Tramica's old life is a big old pine tree, which she never cared for anyway Don't miss my pine tree because it puts sap during the wintertime and everything on the core So she may not miss her pine tree, but she does miss this place. It's bittersweet coming back here now just to see all the houses that are gone because this whole row were all homes. Chermica moved to Lake Charles when she was in high school.
我来这里是为了你以前的车道。就是这个。这就是我的车道。在这里呆了二十多年。我正和特拉米卡·兰金斯（Tramica Rankins）一起站在她以前的房子所在的空地上。特拉米卡旧生活中唯一留下的是一棵老松树，她以前根本不在乎它。别想念我的松树，因为它在冬天会分泌树脂和各种树液。所以她可能不会想念她的松树，但她确实想念这个地方。现在回到这里，只为了看到所有消失的房子，这种感觉是苦乐参半的，因为这一整排以前全都是家。谢米卡（Chermica）上高中时搬到了查尔斯湖。
She got married here, had kids, and eventually started looking for a home to buy. And she found a house she could afford in the Greenwich Terrace. Nice little house, nice little neighborhood, older people. Hey, great, cool. She had initially thought of the house as a starter home, a stepping stone on a journey to something bigger and better. But life got in the way, and they ended up spending over two decades in the terrace. And it was a good place to raise kids.
她在这里结婚，有了孩子，最终开始寻找要买的房子。她在格林威治特拉丝找到了一所她买得起的房子。漂亮的小房子，漂亮的社区，老年人。嘿，太棒了，很酷。她最初认为这所房子是一个起步房，是通往更大更好事物旅程中的一块跳板。但生活总有波折，他们最终在特拉丝度过了二十多年。这是一个抚养孩子的好地方。
They had neighbors who looked after each other and also knew how to have a good time. And I used to at least wake up on a Saturday morning to somebody going down the neighborhood with their cars, music foaming. You hear somebody in the neighborhood fussing. You hear, you know, you smell the barbecue going or somebody fixing on a car.
他们有互相关照的邻居，也知道如何过得开心。我过去常常至少在周六早晨醒来时，听到有人开着车在社区里转悠，音乐震天响。你会听到社区里有人在唠叨。你会听到，你知道，你会闻到烤肉的香味，或者有人在修理汽车。
She says the terrace was full of funny characters, like her next door neighbor. He meant well, but he kept the neighborhood ready. Anytime he step out of the house, you know, he's about to do something, fishing wasn't supposed to. There was a lot of colorful activities that may have happened in the neighborhood. The terrace wasn't Tremica's dream, but it worked for her.
她说特拉丝充满了滑稽的人物，比如她的隔壁邻居。他是好意，但总是让社区处于戒备状态。他每次走出家门，你都知道，他要做点什么，有些事他本不该去钓鱼。社区里发生了许多多姿多彩的活动。特拉丝并不是特拉米卡的梦想，但对她来说够用了。
At least until 2017. That's when Lake Charles got hit, with the first in what would be a string of devastating storms. Hurricane Harvey barreling into the Texas coastline, that could render some areas uninhabitable for months. Hurricane Harvey overwhelmed the drainage canal in the back of the terrace called the Cayuchi Cooley and flooded the neighborhood.
至少直到2017年。正是在那时，查尔斯湖受到了袭击，这是一连串毁灭性风暴中的第一场。飓风哈维（Harvey）直扑得克萨斯州海岸线，这可能会使一些地区数月内无法居住。飓风哈维淹没了特拉丝后方名为卡尤奇·库利（Cayuchi Cooley）的排水渠，并淹没了社区。
Tramica was shocked. I've been here for 17, 18 years, nothing ever happened. So maybe it was a fluke. Maybe it was a lot of rain that we just could not soak up. She made repairs, but now she was worried. The drainage infrastructure in the terrace couldn't handle Harvey. It's gonna happen again.
特拉米卡惊呆了。我在这里呆了17、18年，从来没发生过什么事。所以也许这只是个巧合。也许只是下了太多我们无法吸收的雨。她进行了修补，但现在她开始担心了。特拉丝的排水基础设施无法应付哈维。这还会再次发生。
When? We don't know, but it will. Fast forward to 2020. Hurricane Laura came through and demolished the city. One of the strongest storms to ever hit the US left its mark on just about every part of Lake Charles. This second hurricane, Hurricane Laura, displaced thousands of people throughout Lake Charles. The 150 mile an hour winds knocked a tree into the back of Tormica's house, but the terrace stayed dry. I don't know if you can call that luck,
什么时候？我们不知道，但它会发生。快进到2020年。飓风劳拉（Laura）过境，摧毁了这座城市。这场袭击美国的最强风暴之一在查尔斯湖的几乎每个地方都留下了痕迹。第二场飓风“劳拉”导致查尔斯湖各地的数千人流离失所。每小时150英里的风速将一棵树刮倒砸中了特拉米卡家的后方，但特拉丝保持了干爽。我不知道这能不能叫幸运，
but whatever it was, it didn't last. Just a few weeks after Laura had came in August, maybe six weeks later, here comes Delta. Before the city of Lake Charles could even attempt to get back on its feet, another hurricane started bearing down on southwest Louisiana, this time Hurricane Delta. It's hard to believe that it's happening again.
但不管是什么，它并没有持续多久。就在劳拉登陆几周后，大约六周后，德尔塔（Delta）来了。在查尔斯湖市甚至还没来得及重新站起来之前，另一场飓风开始逼近路易斯安那州西南部，这次是飓风德尔塔。真难以置信这一切又发生了。
Another hurricane hitting the U.S. Tramica and her family evacuated to Houston. They waited out the storm at a hotel. But when they got back home, it was obvious what had happened. There were worms at the bottom of the bathtub, lizards inside the house, and the whole place smelled awful. I remember my two-year-old grandson looking at me and he's coming outside and he's just shaking his head.
另一场飓风袭击了美国。特拉米卡和她的家人撤离到了休斯顿。他们在一家酒店度过了风暴。但当他们回到家时，发生的事情显而易见。浴缸底部有蠕虫，房子里有蜥蜴，整个地方闻起来臭气熏天。我记得我两岁的孙子看着我，他走到外面直摇头。
I'm like, what's wrong, baby? He said, again? Again, mama? Again? I was like, unfortunately, baby, again. The family was back to square one. They needed to gut the house and rebuild all over again. Tramica had tried to get flood insurance after Harvey, but there'd been a mix-up, and so
我说，怎么了，宝贝？他说，又来了？又来了吗，妈妈？又来了？我说，不幸的是，宝贝，又来了。一家人回到了原点。他们需要彻底清理房屋并重新开始重建。哈维过后，特拉米卡曾试图购买洪水保险，但出现了一些混乱，所以
they had to pay for everything out of pocket. Still, she says that her family was lucky to be able to make repairs at all. Many of the older folks in the neighborhood who were living on fixed incomes just didn't have the resources. You know, it broke my heart after Delta. You know, I was repairing everything, doing what I had to do. But I watched the older lady open up her door, her screen door, raise up her windows, kept the same curtains in the house, but she tied them up for it to get sunlight.
他们不得不自掏腰包支付所有费用。尽管如此，她还是说她的家人很幸运，至少还能进行维修。社区里许多靠固定收入生活的老年人根本没有这些资源。你知道，德尔塔之后我心碎了。你知道，我在修补一切，做我必须做的事。但我看着一个老太太打开她的门，她的纱门，推开她的窗户，屋里挂着同样的窗帘，但她把它们扎起来以便让阳光照进来。
She's taking a squeegee and squeezing the water out of her home, and she couldn't do nothing else. You can still see evidence of these hurricanes in Lake Charles today, and the uneven way that different neighborhoods were able to bounce back. In a federally recognized disaster like Hurricane Delta, FEMA will provide direct relief to survivors, but it's often slow to arrive and insufficient when it finally does. And over the years, FEMA has been widely criticized for giving more relief to white people than it does to people of color. Meanwhile, people in wealthier neighborhoods are also more likely to have insurance or just be able to pay for rebuilding out of pocket. The end result of all that is that when you drive around the wealthier, often whiter neighborhoods in South Lake Charles today, you would have no idea that these hurricanes even happened. But in the mostly black working
她拿着刮水板把家里的水刮出去，她别无他法。今天你仍然可以在查尔斯湖看到这些飓风的痕迹，以及不同社区恢复能力的参差不齐。在像飓风德尔塔这样联邦认定的灾难中，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）将向幸存者提供直接救济，但它往往姗姗来迟，而且在最终到达时杯水车薪。多年来，FEMA因向白人提供的救济多于有色人种而受到广泛批评。与此同时，较富裕社区的人们也更有可能拥有保险，或者只是能够自掏腰包进行重建。这一切的最终结果是，当你今天开车穿过南查尔斯湖更富裕、通常更白人的社区时，你根本不会知道这些飓风曾经发生过。但在北查尔斯湖主要是黑人的工人阶级社区，
class neighborhoods in North Lake Charles, it's a very different story. You know, there's a, there's, I just passed three houses with blue tarps, four houses right there with blue tarps still on their roof. There are still so many blue tarps where a roof should be. It looks like the hurricanes happened months ago, not years. We're talking in, you know, upwards of upwards of two, three years ago at this point. You can really see a lot of damage still from the storm, or storms really, like a lot of houses that still don't feel like they've been fully rebuilt. Many of the people who were displaced in these storms
情况大不相同。你知道，有，有，我刚路过三栋挂着蓝色防水布的房子，那边还有四栋房子的屋顶上依然盖着蓝色防水布。本该是屋顶的地方依然有那么多的蓝色防水布。这看起来像是几个月前发生的飓风，而不是几年前。我们说的是，你知道，在这一点上已经过去了两三年了。你真的可以看到风暴造成的很多破坏依然存在，或者说是多场风暴，比如很多房子依然感觉没有得到完全重建。在这些风暴中流离失所的许多人
still haven't returned home. According to data from the US Postal Service, between 2019 and 2020, Lake Charles lost more of its population to out-migration than any other city in the country. Back at the terrace, as the waters receded and the repairs began, two very different stories started to emerge about why this neighborhood in particular seemed to be so vulnerable to
至今还没有回家。根据美国邮政服务的数据，在2019年至2020年期间，查尔斯湖因人口外迁而流失的人口比国内任何其他城市都要多。回到特拉丝，随着水位退去和维修开始，关于为什么这个社区似乎如此容易受到
flooding. The first story from the local government's perspective was that the flooding situation was caused by a devilish mix of overlapping problems, including climate change. You're certainly seeing things that have never happened before. Jennifer Kobian is the grants director for Kaukeshoe Parish, where Lake Charles is located. She grew up in southwest Louisiana, so she's used to big storms. But the pileup of disasters in recent years
洪水侵袭，开始出现两个截然不同的故事。从地方政府的角度来看，第一个说法是，洪水情况是由一系列相互交织的问题（包括气候变化）恶魔般地混合造成的。你肯定会看到以前从未发生过的事情。詹妮弗·科比安（Jennifer Kobian）是查尔斯湖所在的卡尔克苏教区（Calcasieu Parish）的拨款总监。她在路易斯安那州西南部长大，所以她习惯了大风暴。但近年来灾难的堆积
was eyebrow raising. We were certainly thinking, this doesn't feel right for it to be back to back like that. That's the red flag, the indicator of this feels a little different. As wild as this sounds, Jennifer actually thinks that Lake Charles has been lucky not to get hit with an even bigger storm
令人侧目。我们确实在想，这样接二连三地发生，感觉不太对劲。这是一个危险信号，是感觉有点不对劲的指标。听起来可能很疯狂，但詹妮弗实际上认为查尔斯湖在过去几年里很幸运，没有遭到更大风暴的袭击。
in the last few years. We did not see the major catastrophic rain that our neighbors just to the east of us and southeast Louisiana saw and then the 50 inches of rain that just to the west of us in East Texas saw with Hurricane Harvey. Which is a crazy thing to think about a city that's been through as much as you have that there's something worse coming out there. through as much as you have that there's something worse coming out there. Jennifer says that these supercharged storms are particularly problematic for Lake Charles because the city is so low lying. And although Lake Charles is about 30 miles from the coast, it sits along the Calcasieu River, a tidal waterway that is rising with the seas. And so when there's a big hurricane in the Gulf of Mexico, the storm surge pushes a whole
我们没有看到我们东边的邻居和路易斯安那州东南部所经历的那种重大灾难性降雨，也没有看到我们西边的邻居德克萨斯州东部在飓风哈维期间遭遇的50英寸降雨。对于一个经历过你所经历的那么多苦难的城市来说，这是一个疯狂的想法，那就是外面还有更糟糕的事情要来。经历过你所经历的那么多苦难的城市来说，外面还有更糟糕的事情要来。詹妮弗说，这些超级充能的风暴对查尔斯湖来说尤其成问题，因为这座城市地势太低了。尽管查尔斯湖距离海岸约30英里，但它沿卡尔克苏河而建，这是一条随着海平面上升而上涨的潮汐水道。因此，当墨西哥湾发生大飓风时，风暴潮会将大量的水一路向上推到查尔斯湖，这使得该市更难排水。
bunch of water all the way up the river to Lake Charles, which makes it harder for the city to drain. It basically acts like a little stopper to all of our waterways. When you add rain events, especially historical torrential rain events, on top of that, there's nowhere for the water to go. It spills out of the bayous and the coolies and into the city, where it starts to pool in the lowest-lying spots. So this is the Greenwich Terrace neighborhood right here.
它基本上就像我们所有水道的一个小塞子。当你再加上降雨事件，尤其是历史上百年一遇的暴雨事件时，水就无处可去了。它从河口和沟渠溢出，流入城市，开始在最低洼的地方汇聚。所以这就是格林威治特拉丝社区。
Jennifer pulls up a map of Lake Charles on her computer. It shows the ground surface elevation throughout the city. Higher elevations are red and the lower elevations are blue. And as she scrolls towards the terrace, the map gets very blue. It is sort of the low spot of a low spot, if you would. So that water is all rolling off and draining towards that neighborhood. Jennifer says that when the neighborhood was first developed, this was less of a problem because it was surrounded by a lot of empty fields that could absorb runoff during a rainstorm.
詹妮弗在电脑上调出了查尔斯湖的地图。它显示了整个城市的地表高程。较高的高程是红色的，较低的高程是蓝色的。当她向特拉丝滚动时，地图变得非常蓝。如果你愿意的话，它可以说是低洼之地的低洼地。所以所有的水都在向下滚动，并向那个社区排水。詹妮弗说，当这个社区最初开发时，这不是什么大问题，因为它被许多空旷的田野包围着，这些田野可以在暴雨期间吸收径流。
But in the 80s and 90s, Lake Charles sprawled outward and enveloped the terrace, encircling the neighborhood in big box stores, parking lots, and the 210 highway. And so now, when you get a lot of rain in a short period of time, the water runs off all that pavement and heads straight for the low spot on the map. There are a series of pumps that are supposed to help relieve pressure on the system, but Jennifer says they just haven't been able to handle some of these storms. They can only pump so much so fast and at the rate of rainfall, it just can't keep up
但在80和90年代，查尔斯湖向外扩张并吞没了特拉丝，用大卖场、停车场和210号公路将社区包围。因此，现在，当你在短时间内得到大量降雨时，水就会从所有这些路面上流过，直奔地图上的低洼地。有一系列泵本应有助于减轻系统的压力，但詹妮弗说，它们根本无法应对其中一些风暴。它们只能以如此的速度抽取一定量的水，而在降雨率面前，它根本跟不上，
and that's when flooding happens. I asked Jennifer to try and sum up what exactly went wrong during these floods in the terrace. And she said it was a wicked combination of factors. Extreme rainfall, a low-lying community surrounded by asphalt, an aging drainage infrastructure that just wasn't designed to cope with this amount of water. It's sort of a lot of little things that add up to be a big thing. It may have been true that the Terrace was facing a series of interlocking problems that
这就是洪水发生的时候。我请詹妮弗试着总结一下特拉丝这些洪水期间究竟出了什么问题。她说这是一系列因素的恶性组合。极端的降雨，被沥青包围的低洼社区，以及根本无法应对这么大水量老化的排水基础设施。这有点像是许多小问题加起来变成了一个大问题。特拉丝面临着一系列相互交织的问题，这可能是真的，
didn't have any easy solutions. But that wasn't a very satisfying explanation for people who were actually living there. And here's where the second narrative comes in. A lot of residents of the terrace felt like the government just hadn't done enough to protect them. There was a lot of skepticism about those pumps
这些问题并没有简单的解决方案。但这对于实际住在那里的人来说并不是一个非常令人满意的解释。这就是第二个说法的切入点。特拉丝的许多居民觉得政府做得还不够来保护他们。人们对那些泵
and whether they had even been turned on during that crazy series of storms. And when Tremieka Rankins kept hearing city and parish officials saying that there wasn't much they could do about these unprecedented 100-year floods, it started to drive her crazy. How you gonna keep telling me it's a freaking 100-year flood?
以及在狂风暴雨期间它们是否真的被打开过存有很大怀疑。当特拉米卡·兰金斯不断听到市和教区官员说他们对这些前所未有的百年一遇洪水无能为力时，她快被逼疯了。你怎么能一直告诉我这是一场百年一遇的洪水？
Well, God dang it. We in the last days, it's because 100 years come in every six months. Straight up. Like, don't insult my intelligence. It's called, you guys, infrastructure is horrible. And Tramica's bigger problem is that not all of the infrastructure
好吧，见鬼去吧。我们正处于末日，这是因为每六个月就会来一次百年。直截了当。听着，不要侮辱我的智商。这叫作，你们的frastracture基础设施太糟糕了。特拉米卡更大的问题是，查尔斯湖并非所有的基础设施
in Lake Charles is horrible. If you go to a newer, wealthier, often whiter neighborhood that was built to more recent standards, you'll see a drain at the end of every driveway. But that's just not the case in the terrace. I'm just saying that you did not invest in any kind of infrastructure or drainage structure here in the area that could have maybe offset this. That's what I'm saying. What I'm saying is, you have maliciously avoided to even help this area.
都很糟糕。如果你去一个按照最新标准建造的更新、更富裕、通常更白人的社区，你会看到每个车道尽头都有一个排水沟。但特拉丝的情况并非如此。我只是说，你没有在这里投资任何类型的排水基础设施或排水结构，这本可以抵消这一点。这就是我要说的。我要说的是，你们恶意回避甚至不愿帮助这个地区。
The flooding was new, but for Tramica and for many other residents of the terrace, it also felt like the latest chapter in a much larger story. A story about how there were no longer any grocery stores in the neighborhood. How the local bank closed down and the Walgreens moved away. Climate impacts don't happen in isolation. The climate is changing on top
洪水是新的，但对特拉米卡和特拉丝的许多其他居民来说，这也感觉像是更大故事中的最新章节。一个关于社区里不再有任何杂货店的故事。当地银行如何倒闭，沃尔格林如何搬走。气候影响不会孤立发生。气候变化叠加在
of a pre-existing infrastructure of inequality. And so when Tramica heard government officials blaming the floods on these unprecedented storms and climate change, it almost felt like a convenient excuse, a way to avoid accountability for failing to invest in her community. It's a combination of climate change. I'm not saying that that does not play a fact in it.
预先存在的不平等基础设施之上。因此，当特拉米卡听到政府官员将洪水归咎于这些前所未有的风暴和气候变化时，这几乎感觉像是一个方便的借口，一种逃避未能投资于她的社区的问责的方式。这是气候变化的结合。我并不是说这没有起到作用。
But what you allocating your dollars to care for and do has a lot to do with what's happened here. Tremica started calling the city, demanding that something be done to fix the drainage problem. Enough is enough. How do you expect somebody to stay sane and you keep doing the same thing till it's over and over and you don't expect anybody to rise up
但你们将资金分配给什么并为此做些什么，与这里发生的事情有很大关系。特拉米卡开始打电话给市政府，要求采取措施解决排水问题。受够了。你怎么能指望一个人保持理智，而你们却一遍又一遍地做同样的事情直到结束，却不指望任何人站出来
and say anything about it. She kept calling and calling. She even got in touch with the mayor and told him that he needed to do more to protect the terrorists, but she also made extra sure to protect herself. She got flood insurance for real this time. Her new policy kicked in on May 16th, 2021. And I kid you not just one day after it went into effect, Lake Charles got hit with one of the largest rainstorms in the city's history.
说点什么呢。她不停地打电话。她甚至联系了市长，告诉他他需要做更多的工作来保护特拉丝，但她也格外努力地保护自己。这次她真的买了好洪水保险。她的新政策于2021年5月16日生效。我开玩笑，就在它生效的一天后，查尔斯湖就遭遇了该市历史上最大的暴雨之一。
My insurance kicked in May 16th, and May 17th was a flood. Over a foot of rain fell on Lake Charles in less than a day. The storm was totally unexpected, and so there was no time to evacuate. Tramica and her son were actually in their house when water started spilling out of the coulee. She knew this could get ugly, and so she started running around, unplugging TVs and appliances, and just trying to get their most valuable possessions off the ground. Her son was looking at her like, what are you doing? He's like, what's wrong, mama?
我的保险在5月16日生效，5月17日就发了洪水。查尔斯湖在不到一天的时间里降下了超过一英尺的雨。这场风暴完全出乎意料，因此根本没有时间撤离。当水开始从沟渠里溢出来时，特拉米卡和她的儿子其实正在家里。她知道这可能会变得糟糕，所以她开始四处奔跑，拔掉电视和电器的插头，只想把他们最宝贵的财产搬离地面。她的儿子看着她，心想你在干什么？他说，妈妈，怎么了？
I'm like, the water's coming. I don't know when it's coming, but it's coming. And then she heard the sound of her son's car in the driveway. I heard my son's car. I'll never forget it. It was like beep, beep, beep, baa, baa. The car died, submerged in floodwater. And then the water was inside the house.
我说，水来了。我不知道它什么时候来，但它正在来。然后她听到了儿子车在车道上的声音。我听到了我儿子的车。我永远不会忘记。就像哔，哔，哔，叭，叭。汽车熄火了，淹没在洪水之中。然后水流进了屋子里。
I said, the water's here. And I looked out my window. And I felt like the people that fell in the Titanic. And the water came in so fast and so vigorous that it knocked the shoes off my feet and it made me fall into the water. And I'm six foot something, as you can tell. The water was over my waist. Tremica climbed onto the back of the couch
我说，水来了。我看着窗外。我觉得自己就像掉进泰坦尼克号里的人一样。水涌进来得如此之快、如此猛烈，以至于把我的鞋子都冲掉了，把我撞倒在水中。如你所见，我身高六英尺多。水已经没过了我的腰。特拉米卡爬到沙发靠背上，
and in the middle of this drenched chaos called her insurance agent, just to double check that her new policy, that one that was supposed to kick in the day before, was definitely active. When I set up my house, it's filled with water. She said, there's no freaking way. I've never had anyone call me within 20,
在这湿漉漉的混乱中给她的保险代理人打电话，只是为了仔细检查她的新政策——那份本应在前一天生效的政策——是否确实处于激活状态。当我收拾好房子时，里面全是水。她说，绝无可能。我从来没遇到过有人在20天内打电话给我，
not even 24 hours and the, are you serious? I said, yes ma'am. I said, I can show you pictures. I'm showing a picture of the water. She's like, oh my God. The May 17th storm was a turning point for Trameka. May 17th literally changed my life. That changed the way that I saw things,
甚至不到24小时，而且，你是认真的吗？我说，是的，夫人。我说，我可以给你看照片。我正在展示水的照片。她说，哦，天哪。5月17日的风暴对特拉米卡来说是一个转折点。5月17日彻底改变了我的生活。这改变了我看事物的方式，
because that was like a mental snap. There's no way I'm not going to live in this house any much longer. Like, I just can't make it make sense anymore. If the government wasn't going to improve the drainage situation, Tramica didn't know what to do. She didn't feel like she could justify rebuilding her house again in what had clearly become a dangerous location.
因为那就像是一次精神上的崩塌。我绝不可能在这栋房子里再住多久了。就像，我再也无法让它合乎情理了。如果政府不打算改善排水状况，特拉米卡不知道该怎么办。她觉得自己在显然已经变成危险地点的地方无法证明再次重建房屋是合理的。
She needed help. Coming up after the break, help arrives. But it's not what Tramica was looking for. When we left off, Tramica Rankins was demanding solutions to the Terrace's flooding problems. And it turns out that someone was trying to figure out a solution. A man named Pat Forbes. I'm Pat Forbes. I'm the executive director of the Louisiana Office of Community Development. Pat heads up a statewide program called the Watershed Initiative, which tries to make Louisiana more resilient to the floods of the future.
她需要帮助。休息过后，帮助即将到来。但这并不是特拉米卡一直在寻找的。在我们离开时，特拉米卡·兰金斯正在要求解决特拉丝的洪水问题。事实证明，有人一直在试图找出解决方案。一个名叫帕特·福布斯（Pat Forbes）的人。我是帕特·福布斯。我是路易斯安那州社区发展办公室的执行主任。帕特领导着一个名为“流域倡议”（Watershed Initiative）的全州项目，该项目试图让路易斯安那州更能抵御未来的洪水。
Rainstorms are going to be more intense and more frequent. And so consequently, what we think we know about where the risk begins and ends from flooding is probably out the window. Traditionally, the government has managed flooding mostly with hard infrastructure and technology, things like pumps and levees. But as flood risk increases because of climate change, people like Pat are starting to come around to a different strategy. It's called managed retreat.
暴雨将更加猛烈和频繁。因此，随之而来的是，我们自以为对洪水风险起止点的了解可能已经不合时宜了。传统上，政府主要通过硬基础设施和技术（如水泵和堤防）来管理洪水。但随着气候变化导致洪水风险增加，像帕特这样的人开始转向不同的策略。这被称为管理式退让（managed retreat）。
Yeah, I don't hate the idea. Managed retreat is much more efficient than chaotic retreat, and it's a lot less disruptive to people's lives. The idea is that with so many looming climate threats, it just isn't possible to protect every place with infrastructure, things like bigger levees or better drainage. We can't hold the line and defend every piece of property against rising seas and supercharged storms. And so, in particularly risky places, the safest, most resilient option might be to
是的，我不讨厌这个想法。管理式退让比混乱的退让要高效得多，对人们生活的干扰也小得多。这个想法是，面对如此多迫在眉睫的气候威胁，单靠基础设施（如更大的堤防或更好的排水系统）根本无法保护每一个地方。我们无法坚守阵线并保卫每一处财产免受海平面上升和超级风暴的侵袭。因此，在风险特别高的 地方，最安全、最有韧性的选择可能是
try and get everyone out of harm's way. There's not enough money in the world for us to build our way out of flood risk. We're going to have to start getting out of the way where we never should have gotten in the way in the first place. Managed retreat is not a totally new idea. There's a famous example where the town of Valmeyer, Illinois moved away from the Mississippi River and onto higher ground after the big flood of 1993. And Pat has actually moved several flood-prone towns or neighborhoods in Louisiana, including
尝试让每个人都脱离危险。世界上没有足够的资金让我们通过建设来摆脱洪水风险。我们必须开始从我们本不该涉足的地方撤退。管理式退让并不是一个全新的概念。有一个著名的例子，在1993年的大洪水之后，伊利诺伊州瓦尔迈尔（Valmeyer）镇从密西西比河搬到了地势更高的地方。帕特实际上已经迁移了路易斯安那州的几个易受洪水影响的城镇或社区，其中包括
a couple where they have built a whole new community for everyone to move to together. And so they remain neighbors. Instead of having that be a diaspora, have them go live together somewhere else. But building an entire new neighborhood is really, really expensive. And so often they'll use a different tool to try and get people to safety. The buyout.
几个他们为每个人一起搬迁而建造了全新社区的例子。所以他们仍然是邻居。与其让其成为流散，不如让他们去别的地方一起生活。但建立一个全新的社区非常非常昂贵。所以他们通常会使用不同的工具来试图让人们安全。购回（buyout）。
In a buyout, the government just pays people for their flood prone homes and lets them choose where they want to move. Then they demolish the old houses and ideally convert the land back into a wetland or a reservoir or something that can store water during a storm and help reduce flooding throughout the city. I mean, they can be parks and things like that that flood when it floods, but it won't
在购回中，政府只需为他们易受洪水影响的房屋向人们付款，并让他们选择想搬到哪里去。然后他们拆除旧房屋，理想情况下将土地恢复为湿地或水库，或者在风暴期间可以储存水并有助于减少整个城市洪水的其他设施。我的意思是，它们可以成为公园之类的东西，在发洪水时会被淹没，但它
be people's houses. For Pat, this is an equity issue because while flooding certainly affects wealthy people with homes along the beach, it's actually a much more common problem for working-class communities and communities of color. There are a lot of reasons why that's the case. Sometimes racist housing policies like redlining pushed people on to flood-prone land. Sometimes the government has just failed to maintain the infrastructure. And often the lowest lying land is just cheaper.
不会是人们的房子。对帕特来说，这是一个公平问题，因为虽然洪水当然会影响沿海拥有房屋的富人，但它实际上是工人阶级社区和有色人种社区更常见的问题。造成这种情况的原因有很多。有时，种族主义的住房政策（如画红线）将人们推向易受洪水影响的土地。有时政府只是未能维护基础设施。而且往往最低洼的土地只是更便宜。
Pat sees buyouts as an effort to address the mistakes of the past, the development decisions and housing policies that put a lot of marginalized people at risk. A lot of people have paid very steep price for development in floodplains. They've essentially had their opportunity for building generational wealth stolen from them
帕特将购回视为一项解决过去错误、即让许多边缘化人群处于危险之中的开发决策和住房政策的努力。许多人为在洪泛区进行开发付出了非常沉重的代价。他们建立代际财富的机会基本上被剥夺了，
because their house is actually depreciated instead of appreciating. Pat talks about the buyout like a ladder out of a money pit. Our funds are focused on helping the most vulnerable people in the communities. We don't go do buyouts for affluent folks, right, on the beach or something.
因为他们的房屋实际上是在贬值而不是升值。帕特将购回比作摆脱金钱陷阱的梯子。我们的资金专注于帮助社区中最脆弱的人。我们不会为富裕阶层、海滩上的人等做购回。
Those aren't our targets. It's the people who have been shortchanged in the past and need an opportunity for a restart. Pat heard about the flooding in Greenwich Terrace from a local official and sent people to check out the area. And then when that final May flood happened, it was like, okay, this neighborhood meets all the criteria. And then that's when we set about setting up a buyout program for Greenwich Terrace. The Watershed Initiative allocated 30 million dollars to buy out
这些不是我们的目标。这是那些过去受到不公平对待并且需要重新开始机会的人。帕特从一位地方官员那里听说了格林威治特拉丝的洪水情况，并派人去查看该地区。然后，当最后一次5月的洪水发生时，就像是，好吧，这个社区符合所有标准。然后我们着手为格林威治特拉丝建立购回计划。流域倡议拨款3000万美元购回
the most vulnerable homes in the terrace. But for a lot of the people actually living in the terrace, the buyout raised this question. If you've got 30 million dollars to help us out, why not just use that money to fix the drainage? You know, we could have just fixed the flooding situation and plumb it with all the money that they spent to buy the homes and then tear them down. You could have just invested the money into the plumbing, to the drainage. This is a man I met who still lives in the terrace. He didn't want to give his name, but he had a lot to say about the buyout program. He lives just outside the zone of houses that are eligible, so he wasn't offered a buyout.
特拉丝最脆弱的房屋。但对于许多实际住在特拉丝的人来说，购回引发了这样一个问题。如果你有3000万美元来帮助我们，为什么不直接用这笔钱来修理排水系统呢？你知道，我们可以用他们花在购买房屋然后将其拆除的所有钱来解决洪水情况并铺设管道。你本可以将资金投资于管道，投资于排水。这是一个我遇到的仍然住在特拉丝的人。他不想透露姓名，但他对购回计划有很多话要说。他住在符合条件的房屋区之外，所以他没有获得购回的提议。
But he wishes that money could have been spent on a solution that would have allowed everyone to stay. You know, as you can see here, we need a drain here on this street. That way the water would drain. Are you worried about more flooding? I worry about flooding every day when it rains. You know, that's something we worry about in an area every day. You know, it's not just flooding here in the Greenwich Territories, it's flooding in other areas in the city. But I really believe that to correct the problem is to correct the drainage.
但他希望这笔钱能花在能让每个人都留下来的解决方案上。你知道，正如你在这里看到的，我们需要这条街上有个排水沟。这样水就能排出去。你担心更多的洪水吗？我每天下雨时都担心洪水。你知道，这是我们在一个地区每天都担心的事。你知道，不仅格林威治特拉丝有洪水，城市其他地方也有洪水。但我真的相信解决问题的方法就是解决排水问题。
Fix the drainage first, then you'll fix the problem. Many people I talk to express similar feelings. And it's really no surprise that fixing the drainage would be a more popular option than a buyout. People are always going to prefer a solution that allows them to remain in a community that they love. A recurring feeling that I feel like a lot of people have of like, we could have used that money differently. You know, $30 million. Why wasn't that money used to protect this neighborhood in some way?
先修好排水，然后你就能解决问题。我交谈过的许多人表达了类似的情感。修复排水系统比购回更受欢迎，这实在不足为奇。人们总是会更喜欢允许他们留在自己热爱的社区的解决方案。一种经常出现的感觉是，我觉得很多人都有这种感觉，即我们可以用不同的方式使用这笔钱。你知道，3000万美元。为什么不用这笔钱以某种方式保护这个社区呢？
I put this question to Jennifer Kobian, the grants director for Kalkushu Parish. What do you say to that? Jennifer Kobian Yeah, I mean, that decision was made at the state level and was sort of offered to the community to participate in the buyout program. We did not have an offer on the table to do a drainage improvement project. So we didn't have a choice between a drainage improvement project or a buyout. We only had the buyout on the table. Jennifer says that the parish is trying to get grants
我把这个问题抛给了卡尔克苏教区的拨款总监詹妮弗·科比安。你对此有什么看法？詹妮弗·科比安：是的，我的意思是，这个决定是在州一级做出的，并某种程度上提供给社区参与购回计划。我们桌面上没有提供排水改善项目的提议。所以我们在排水改善项目和购回之间没有选择。我们桌面上只有购回。詹妮弗说，该教区正试图获得拨款
to improve the capacity of the pumps in that area. But she's not sure how much they can lower the overall risk. Drainage improvement will have some improvement to the area, but it will not eliminate the flood risk, just given the low topography of the neighborhood. They're low. Those houses are sitting really low. Like, if a house was built there today,
来提高该地区水泵的容量。但她不确定他们能将整体风险降低多少。排水改善会对该地区有所改善，但它不会消除洪水风险，鉴于该社区低洼的地形。它们很低。那些房子坐落得很低。就像，如果今天在那里建房子，
they'd have to build four feet higher than where they're at right now. Jennifer said that buyouts should always be the last option, but there just wasn't a great alternative. And when the state called offering money, it wasn't something she felt she could afford to turn down. It seemed like the best way to get people help as quickly as possible.
它们必须建得比现在高四英尺。詹妮弗说，购回应该一直是最后的选择，但实在没有更好的替代方案。当州里打电话提供资金时，她觉得这不是她能负担得起拒绝的东西。这似乎是尽快让人们得到帮助的最佳方式。
It may well be true that there wasn't a viable way to fix the drainage situation in the terrace. But I think this situation raises an important question about climate adaptation. Who is being offered solutions that allow them to remain in place? And who is being asked to move? A lot of this is driven by economics. This is Anna Weber, a senior policy analyst with the NRDC. She says that a lot of decisions about whether or not to build new protective infrastructure, things like seawalls or new pumps, are determined in part by how much, quote, value the project
特拉丝可能确实没有切实可行的办法来解决排水问题，但我觉得这种情况提出了一个关于气候适应的重要问题。谁正在被提供允许他们留在原地的解决方案？谁又被要求搬迁？这很大程度上是由经济学驱动的。这是自然资源保护委员会（NRDC）的高级政策分析师安娜·韦伯（Anna Weber）。她说，关于是否建造新的保护性基础设施（如海堤或新水泵）的许多决定，部分取决于该项目可以保护多少所谓的“价值”，
can protect. It is more, quote unquote, worth it to protect areas of higher value in a financial sense. And that means that on the flip side, areas of quote unquote lower value in a financial sense are often left out. They're not put behind the wall. They're not protected by the structural projects. And they are more likely to get offered a buyout. I want to just pause for a second,
从财务意义上讲，保护更高价值的地区“更值得”。这意味着另一方面，在财务意义上所谓的“价值较低”的地区往往被排除在外。它们没有被置于墙后。它们没有受到结构性项目的保护。而且它们更有可能获得购回的提议。我想暂停一下，
because I think there is a genuine conundrum here. On the one hand, a buyout is a government benefit. And so, of course, you want to give that benefit to the people who need it the most. Communities of color, lower income communities, are much more likely to be faced with the impacts of chronic flooding. And so when buyouts are proposed, it makes sense that these communities might be at the top of the list. They're the ones facing the risks. They're the ones who should get the first chance to relocate.
因为我认为这里确实存在一个真正的难题。一方面，购回是一项政府福利。所以，你当然希望将这项福利给予最需要它的人。有色人种社区、低收入社区更有可能面临长期洪水的冲击。因此，当提出购回时，这些社区名列前茅是有道理的。他们是面临风险的人。他们应该是第一批获得搬迁机会的人。
That makes sense, logically, right? But a buyout is a weird kind of benefit, the kind of benefit that destroys a neighborhood and displaces everyone within it. And so if you're focusing on giving buyouts to working class communities of color, it also means that these communities are effectively being targeted, not in a malicious way, but they are being
从逻辑上讲这说得通，对吧？但购回是一种奇怪的福利，这种福利会摧毁一个社区并使其中的每个人流离失所。因此，如果你专注于向工人阶级有色人种社区提供购回，这也意味着这些社区实际上正成为目标，虽然不是出于恶意，但它们确实成为了目标
prioritized for relocation. And that has additional effects. These are communities that have contributed the least to the problem. These are communities that are facing accumulative impacts, probably of lots of other kinds of challenges, environmental pollution, disinvestment in infrastructure, and now they're being told to relocate. That's a huge problem from a justice standpoint. Anna is in a funny place when it comes to buyouts. In many ways, she's one of their chief critics. I like to clarify when I talk to people about home buyouts, I'm not advocating for buyouts. People are taking a buyout because it's their last option.
被优先考虑搬迁。这会带来更多影响。这些社区对该问题的贡献最小。这些社区正面临着累积的冲击，可能来自各种其他挑战，如环境污染、基础设施投资撤回，而现在他们被告知要搬迁。从正义的角度来看，这是个巨大问题。安娜在房屋回购方面处于一个尴尬的境地。在许多方面，她是这些回购方案的主要批评者之一。每当我和人们谈论房屋回购时，我喜欢澄清一点，我并不是在倡导回购。人们接受回购是因为那是他们最后的选择。
It's their last least bad option. In a lot of ways, I think the best buyout is one that never has to happen in the first place. But she also knows as well as anyone that we're going to need more of them in the years ahead. All throughout the country, there are neighborhoods built on land that is too low or too close to the ocean. And eventually, the water is going to come. In the past 30 years, FEMA has bought out about 43,000 flood-prone properties. But by some estimates, there could be 13 million people living in houses that could regularly flood
这是他们最后的、最不坏的选择。在很多方面，我认为最好的回购是那种根本不需要发生的回购。但她也和任何人一样清楚，在未来几年里，我们需要更多的回购。全国各地都有一些街区建在海拔太低或离海洋太近的土地上。最终，海水终究会漫上来。在过去的30年里，联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）已经回购了大约43,000处易受洪水侵袭的房产。但据一些估计，可能有1300万人住在经常会被淹没的房屋中
by the end of the century. And that's just from sea level rise alone. There are millions more living in low lying floodplains that are vulnerable to supercharged storms. Any way you slice it, there are a lot of vulnerable people who are going to need to move. And so even though she knows about all the problems with buyouts, Anna Weber says we can't really give up
到本世纪末。而这仅仅是由于海平面上升。还有数以百万计的人生活在容易遭受超级风暴袭击的低洼洪泛区。无论你怎么看，都有大量弱势群体将需要搬迁。因此，尽管安娜了解回购带来的所有问题，但她说我们真的不能放弃
on them. We're stuck in this paradoxical situation where the tool that we have to help people move out of harm's way is not very good, but at the same time, it's the only tool that we have, and it needs to scale up in a big way. And so Anna spends a lot of her time trying to make buyouts better. She talks to people all around the country about what it's like to go through the process, including Tramica Rankins.
回购方案。我们陷入了这样一个悖论：我们用来帮助人们远离危险的工具并不是很好，但与此同时，它是我们仅有的工具，而且它需要大幅度升级。因此，安娜花了很多时间试图让回购变得更好。她与全国各地的人们交谈，了解经历这个过程是什么感觉，其中包括特拉米卡·兰金斯。
Back in Greenwich Terrace, it wasn't too long after the May 17th flood that Tramica finally got a call back from the city. From the mayor of Lake Charles, who said he had just spoken with the governor. And they had a new proposal. So I got off the phone with the governor. How do you feel like us buying out your house? Tramica didn't want to leave. She had spent the last several years fighting for her neighborhood.
回到格林威治台地，在5月17日洪水过后不久，特拉米卡终于接到了市里的回访电话。来自查尔斯湖市长的电话，他说他刚刚和州长交谈过。他们提出了一个新的提案。所以我挂了州长的电话。你觉得我们回购你的房子怎么样？特拉米卡并不想离开。过去几年里，她一直在为自己的社区抗争。
But after that third flood, the one where she climbed onto the back of the couch to stay dry, the idea of continuing to live in the terrace just started to seem untenable. She was tired of badgering the city. I'm not going to keep calling you. I'm not going to keep telling you, hey, there's a rainstorm coming. Nobody came and cleaned these drains. I shouldn't have to do that. Trameka had so many good memories in that house.
但在经历第三次洪水之后——那次她爬到沙发靠背上才免于被淹——继续住在台地的想法开始变得难以维持。她厌倦了纠缠市政府。我不会一直给你打电话。我不会一直告诉你，嘿，暴风雨要来了。没有人来清理这些下水管道。我不该去做这些事。特拉米卡在那所房子里留下了那么多美好的回忆。
But now she had all these bad ones, too. And she couldn't seem to shake the memory of wading through way-steep water in her living room. In the end, the decision wasn't that hard. I said, well, it's like a bulldozer to go straight through it right now, pull it right out. I don't care. There is no emotional attachment to the house anymore.
但现在她也有了所有这些糟糕的回忆。而且她似乎无法摆脱在客厅里涉水及腰的那段记忆。最后，决定并不那么艰难。我说，好吧，现在就像派一台推土机直接开过去，把它推倒拉走吧。我不在乎。我对这栋房子已经没有任何情感上的依恋了。
The voluntary buyout program used federal grant money to offer residents the fair market value of their home, and more if they moved to a less flood-prone area. The amount each family would get was determined based on the size of the house and the number of people living there. The most that any single household could get was 250,000. After some negotiation, Tramica and her family were offered 242,000, which Tramica knew was way more
自愿回购计划使用联邦赠款资金向居民提供房屋的公平市场价值，如果他们搬到受洪水影响较小的地区，还会提供更多资金。每个家庭获得的金额根据房屋大小和居住人数来决定。任何单一家庭能获得的最高金额是25万美元。经过一番协商，特拉米卡和她的家人获得了242,000美元的报价，特拉米卡深知这比她
than she was gonna get on the open market for a house that floods all the time. So in the end, it was like, you're giving me what? For a house that's probably not worth nothing now because you don't let it flood so many times? Oh, when do I sign it? Tremica Rankins accepted the buyout in January of 2022. in January of 2022. The buyout took about a year from start to finish. Believe it or not, that's actually really quick. Traditional FEMA buyouts have been known to take closer to five years.
在公开市场上为一栋饱受水淹的房子能卖到的钱要多得多。所以到最后，就像是，你给了我多少？为了一栋现在可能一文不值的房子，因为你任由它被淹了那么多次？哦，我什么时候签字？特拉米卡·兰金斯于2022年1月接受了回购。在2022年1月。回购从头到尾大约花了一年时间。信不信由你，这其实非常快。传统的FEMA回购众所周知通常需要近五年时间。
But even on that fast track, a full year of housing limbo was really challenging for Tramica. And she says that filling out paperwork and jumping through hoops felt like this extremely stressful second job. Yes, the red tape.
但即使在如此快速的通道下，整整一年的住房不确定状态对特拉米卡来说仍然非常具有挑战性。她说，填写文书工作和经历重重官僚阻碍，感觉就像是一份压力极大的第二职业。是的，那些繁文缛节。
I was driving down the street many days, put my hands in my hair, and my hair was coming out of the gloves. That's just how stressful it was. Tramica was particularly stressed about her neighbors, many of whom were a lot older than she was, and they were having a hard time following the process. So she became a volunteer bureaucracy navigator, helping all of the elders on her block understand the ins and outs of the program. So we all conferred like once or twice a week on what we've been told and things like that.
很多天我开车在路上，双手插进头发里，头发一把把地掉下来。事情就是压力这么大。特拉米卡对她的邻居们感到格外焦虑，他们当中许多人比她大得多，而且他们在跟进这个流程时遇到了很大困难。于是她成了一名志愿官僚导航员，帮助她街区的所有老人们理解该计划的内情。所以我们每周开会一两次，讨论我们被告知的事情诸如此类的信息。
And it never was the same. It was like one person say this, but this person say this, this person say this. And it never was the same. It was like, one person say this, we know this person say this, this person say this. And it was crazy. So if I went through something first, I would say, hey, I hit this roadblock. One of the biggest roadblocks was just finding a new house to move into. The two hurricanes had destroyed so many houses
而且情况从来都不是一样的。就像一个人这么说，但另一个人这么说，另一个人这么说。而且情况从来都不是一样的。就像，一个人这么说，我们知道这个人这么说，那个人这么说。这太疯狂了。所以如果我先经历了某些事情，我会说，嘿，我遇到了这个路障。最大的路障之一就是找到一处新房子搬进去。这两场飓风摧毁了如此多的房屋
throughout the city, and the costs of the remaining housing stock jumped accordingly. On top of that, the pool of houses that Tremica could choose from was limited by the program. If she wanted to get the maximum amount of money, she needed to buy a house with significantly lower flood risk. Every house that you looked at, you had to vet it through St. Louisiana. You had to give them the address. Had to tell you whether it was suitable for their program or not. — Based on flood risk or what?
遍布整个城市，剩余住房存量的成本也随之飙升。最重要的是，特拉米卡可选择的房屋范围受到了该项目的限制。如果她想获得最高金额的资金，她就需要购买洪水风险显著较低的房子。你看的每一栋房子，你都必须通过路易斯安那州圣路易斯（St. Louisiana）进行审查。你必须给他们地址。必须告诉你它是否适合他们的计划。——基于洪水风险还是什么？
— So it had to be a flood risk of zero. Not only that, the elevation had to be above flood level. The elevation had to be high. — That's obviously a sensible policy for a buyout program, but it made the housing search a lot more difficult. Because in Lake Charles, the high ground is hard to come by. The state turned down multiple homes that Tramica found because they were too flood prone. But eventually, after months of searching, Tramica found a house that met all her criteria. It had everything she wanted, except the showers were tiny.
— 所以洪水风险必须为零。不仅如此，地势必须高于洪水水位。地势必须很高。— 这对于一个买断项目来说显然是一项明智的政策，但这让寻找住房变得更加困难。因为在查尔斯湖，高地很难找到。州政府拒绝了特拉米卡找到的多栋房屋，因为它们的洪水风险太高。但最终，经过数月的寻找，特拉米卡找到了一栋符合她所有标准的房子。它拥有她想要的一切，只是淋浴间太小了。
I'm standing in a tub and the shower's like right here. I'm like, I'm six foot something. I feel like this is supposed to be for somebody, maybe four or five feet. Like this will not jive with me. But Tramica bought the house, tiny showers and all. It did cost a bit more than what they got in the buyout. So she and her husband have a mortgage again, for the first time in years. They're doing their best to pay it down quickly.
我站在浴缸里，淋浴喷头就在这儿。我想，我有六英尺多高。我觉得这应该是给某个身高也许四五英尺的人准备的。这跟我完全合不来。但特拉米卡买下了这栋房子，小小的淋浴间什么的都不在话下。它的价格确实比他们在回购中获得的资金略高一些。所以她和丈夫多年来第一次又背上了房贷。他们正在尽最大努力尽快还清贷款。
But Tramica says that a new mortgage is a tall order for many of her elderly neighbors. How are you going to get a loan at 75 years old? How are you going to justify that, hey, you know, I got a 30 year mortgage, I'd be 100 plus years old to get a mortgage. Yeah, they had no choice. But even with all the headaches, the lost hair, and the new bills, Tramica says that she knew she made the right decision about the buyout on the day
但特拉米卡说，对于她许多年长的邻居来说，背负新房贷是个不小的要求。你怎么能在75岁高龄时获得贷款？你怎么能证明，嘿，你知道的，我背了30年房贷，我都100多岁了还能背房贷。是的，他们别无选择。但即便有所有的烦恼、脱落的头发和新的账单，特拉米卡说，她知道自己在回购一事上做出了正确的决定，就在那天
her grandson Grayson saw the new house for the first time. So they picked him up from school and brought him here. He's like, where we at? They're like, we're home. So he jumps in the bed with me that night and the sigh of relief he had, he snuggled to me. He woke up at 12 midnight. He said, do we have to leave again? I'm like, no, this is home. Are you sure? I said, yeah. So will it be messy again? I said, I hope not. OK, my boy, you did good. And the sigh of relief that he let out, he went to sleep.
她的孙子格雷森（Grayson）第一次看到新房子。所以他们从学校接他并把他带到这里。他问，我们在哪儿？他们说，我们到家了。于是那天晚上他跳进我的床里，他叹了一口气，依偎在我身边。他在午夜12点醒来。他说，我们还得离开吗？我说，不，这里是家。你确定吗？我说，是的。那还会一团糟吗？我说，希望不会。好吧，我的乖孙，你做的好。他长舒了一口气，然后睡着了。
That's the first night that he had a peaceful, peaceful, peaceful, sound sleep. Tramica says the new neighborhood has taken some getting used to. It's part of a new, neatly planned development. And sometimes it feels a little lifeless compared to the terrace. She misses her noisy neighbors, the sounds of people having barbecues and working on their cars. But she does like the new drain right at the end of the driveway.
那是他度过的第一个平静的、平静的、平静的、安稳的觉。特拉米卡说，新社区需要一些时间去适应。这是一个规划整洁的新开发项目的一部分。有时与台地相比，它显得有些毫无生气。她想念她那些吵闹的邻居，想念人们办烧烤和修理汽车的声音。但她确实很喜欢车道尽头那个崭新的排水沟。
Is this for Halloween? Oh, wow. It's pretty spooky. When I visited her in October, Tramica and Grayson showed me around the new place. There was a giant inflatable skeleton hanging out on the front porch. Yeah, what do you want to be for Halloween?
这是为了万圣节准备的吗？哦，哇。挺吓人的。10月我拜访她时，特拉米卡和格雷森带我参观了新住处。前廊上挂着一个巨大的充气骷髅。是的，万圣节你想扮成什么？
I think a crown. A what? A crown. A crown? A clown, oh. I'm just like, how does it feel? Does this house feel like a home yet to you? I'm getting there. It's home. It takes time.
我想戴个王冠。什么？一个王冠。一个王冠？一个小丑，哦。我只想说，感觉怎么样？这栋房子对你来说感觉像个家了吗？我正在适应。这里是家。这需要时间。
It takes time. I mean, when I wake up and I thank God for putting me in a safe place, you know, thank Him for not having any harm come our way, you know. Within a year I was like, okay, we made it for a year, we're going on two years, no harm has come this way, you know, let's keep it that way, please, am I in good graces now, you know? Because the other house, you had to question yourself, like man, did I do something wrong? Did I piss off the man upstairs or what? Because the other house you had to question yourself like man did I do something wrong that I paid that I'm Piss off the man upstairs. I was
这需要时间。我是说，当我醒来时，我感谢上帝把我带到一个安全的地方，你知道的，感谢祂没有让任何灾难降临到我们头上，你知道的。一年之内我就想，好吧，我们坚持了一年，快要两年了，没有任何灾难降临，你知道的，请继续保持这样，我现在算得上走运了吗，你知道的？因为在另一栋房子里，你不得不质问自己，就像天哪，我是不是做错了什么？我是不是惹恼了楼上那家伙还是怎么着？因为在另一栋房子里你不得不质问自己，就像天哪，我是不是做错了什么，我付出了……我是不是惹恼了楼上那家伙。我当时……
Tramica is trying to embrace her new life, but she's still entangled with Greenwich Terrace She's part of an ongoing lawsuit about the flooding, trying to get damages from the city or the parish for all of the hardship she's endured over the past years. As for the buyouts, so far they've only been offered to the most vulnerable residents, with houses closest to the Coulee. The rest of the people there are waiting to see if more funding becomes available. They're also waiting to see what happens with the empty land. Jennifer Cobian wants to build a park back there that could hold water during a storm. Tramica would like to see something like that.
特拉米卡正试图拥抱她的新生活，但她仍然与格林威治台地纠缠不清。她是一起有关洪水的持续诉讼的参与者，试图向市政府或教区索赔，以补偿她过去几年所忍受的所有苦难。至于回购，到目前为止，它们只提供给了最脆弱的居民，他们的房屋离库利（Coulee）最近。那里其余的人正在等待，看是否会有更多资金到位。他们还在等待看看这片空地会发生什么。詹妮弗·科比安（Jennifer Cobian）想在那后面建一个公园，以便在暴风雨期间蓄水。特拉米卡希望看到类似这样的事情发生。
She would like to know that by moving, she helped make the neighborhood safer for the people who remain. safer for the people who remain. I don't know if you've ever visited a city or a neighborhood that you've lived in before and felt the urge to go drive by your old house. If you've glanced in the window and seen someone else's life just carrying on inside this space that still kind of feels like yours. For Trameka, there was actually no one living in her old house. It belonged to the state, but she still felt that pull.
她希望知道，通过搬迁，她帮助那些留下来的人让社区变得更安全。让留下来的人更安全。我不知道你是否曾拜访过你曾经住过的城市或社区，并有一种冲动想开车路过你的老房子。如果你曾瞥了一眼窗户，看到别人的生活正继续在这个依然感觉有点像你的空间里进行。对特拉米卡来说，实际上没有人住在她的老房子里。它属于州政府，但她仍然感到那种吸引力。
She found herself driving by the terrace on the way home from work, even though it wasn't on her route. Like, I don't know what's drawing me there, but I found myself going out in front of the house and I found myself doing that once or twice a week And then one day she drove by the old house and there was a backhoe punching holes in the roof And I sat there took them all of 15 minutes to do it 15 20 maybe 25 minutes And I cried.
她发现自己下班回家路上会开车经过台地，尽管这并不在她的路线上。就像，我不知道是什么在吸引着我往那儿去，但我发现自己会走到房子前面，我发现自己一周会这么做一两次。然后有一天她开车路过老房子，看到一台反铲挖土机正在屋顶上砸洞。我坐在那里，他们总共花了15分钟就干完了15、20也许25分钟。然后我哭了。
You know? It's wild that you just happened to be there that day. I was just like, jump out, because I wasn't expecting that. She knew that the house would be demolished soon, but she had no idea it was gonna happen while she was sitting right there in her car. She pulled out her phone and took a video of this bizarre scene to send to her husband.
你知道吗？你刚好那天在那儿，这太疯狂了。我当时就想，跳下车，因为我没想到会这样。她知道这栋房子很快就会被拆除，但她没想到会正好在她坐在车里的时候发生。她掏出手机拍下了这个奇异的场景，发给了丈夫。
The little house where they spent decades of their life getting torn apart board by board. I just happened to roll up on this today. I really don't know how I feel about this. I really don't know how I feel about this, she says. Even though Tramica was sure that taking the buyout was the right financial decision, you can hear the ambivalence in her voice. And honestly, I don't know how I feel about it either. When I left Tramica, I drove back to my hotel over the Calcasieu River Bridge,
他们度过了几十年的生活的小房子，正一块木板接一块木板地被拆毁。我今天刚好开到这儿。我真的不知道对此作何感想。我真的不知道对此作何感想，她说。尽管特拉米卡确信接受回购是正确的财务决定，但你能在她的声音中听到这种矛盾心理。老实说，我也不知道自己对此作何感想。当我离开特拉米卡时，我经由卡尔卡苏河大桥（Calcasieu River Bridge）开车返回我的酒店，
past the glittering lights of the petrochemical plants reflecting off the water. And in that moment, I honestly felt overwhelmed at the thought of just how many people will need to endure some version of the brutally stressful, bittersweet process that Tramica went through. How many people will have to move away from a home that they weren't ready to leave? From a kitchen they painted themselves, with the heights of children penciled on the wall? There's no policy fix for that. Coming up next week on Not Built For This, we have an unlikely story of a community that didn't need to move.
驶过在水面上闪烁的石化工厂的灯光倒影。那一刻，我真切地感到不知所措，一想到有多少人将需要经历特拉米卡所经历的那种极其残酷、充满压力的、苦乐参半的过程的某种版本。有多少人将不得不离开一个他们还没准备好离开的家？离开一个他们自己粉刷的厨房，墙上还用铅笔标记着孩子们的身高？对此没有政策上的解决办法。下周在《不属于这里》（Not Built For This）节目中，我们将讲述一个意想不到的故事，关于一个不需要搬迁的社区。
A town that actually got the protective infrastructure it will need to survive in the years to come. And it only took them two decades, many trips to the Pentagon, and thousands of tamales. When we went back to Washington this evening, we were at the Pentagon. The first thing that came out was, you getting any tamales? We did not bring your tamales to the Pentagon. Sorry! You know, that was tamale diplomacy. Ha ha ha ha!
一个小镇，它实际上获得了在未来生存所需的保护性基础设施。而这只花了他二十年时间，多次前往五角大楼，以及数千个玉米粉蒸肉。当我们今晚回到华盛顿特区时，我们在五角大楼。出来的第一句话就是，你带玉米粉蒸肉了吗？我们没有把你的玉米粉蒸肉带到五角大楼。抱歉！你知道，那是玉米粉蒸肉外交。哈哈哈哈！
This episode of Not Built For This was reported and produced by me, Emmett Fitzgerald, along with producers Jason DeLeon and Sophie Kottner, and managing editor Delaney Hall. Further invaluable editing from Christopher Johnson, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, and the boss man, Roman Mars. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez. Theme and original music by George Langford from Actual Magic with additional music by Swan Rayal.
本期《不属于这里》由我，埃mett·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald），以及制作人杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）和苏菲·科特纳（Sophie Kottner），还有执行主编德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）共同报道和制作。克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）以及老板罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）提供了非常宝贵的进一步编辑。混音和声音设计由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）完成。主题曲和原创音乐由来自Actual Magic的乔治·朗福德（George Langford）创作，附加音乐由斯旺·拉亚尔（Swan Rayal）提供。
Fact checking by Liz Boyd. Series art by Aaron Nestor. A huge thank you to everyone we spoke to this week, especially to the incredible Tramika Rankins. Also a big thank you to Roshetta Ozein, the director of The Vessel Project. If you want to support an amazing organization that does climate justice work and grassroots disaster relief in Lake Charles, you can find a link to the Vessel project on our website. I also want to thank Deodra Carmen and Cynthia White, aka The Purple Lady. And finally, a big thank you to my
事实核查由莉兹·博伊德（Liz Boyd）完成。系列艺术由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）创作。非常感谢我们本周交谈的每个人，尤其是了不起的特拉米卡·兰金斯。还要非常感谢“容器项目”（The Vessel Project）的主任罗谢塔·奥泽因（Roshetta Ozein）。如果你想支持一个在查尔斯湖开展气候正义工作和基层灾害救援的了不起的组织，你可以在我们的网站上找到通往“容器项目”的链接。我还想感谢黛德拉·卡门（Deodra Carmen）和辛西娅·怀特（Cynthia White），又名“紫衣女士”（The Purple Lady）。最后，非常感谢我的
good friends Casey Coleman, Susan Sakesh, and Leivon, who put me up and put up with me during my trip to Louisiana. Not Built For This is a six-part series from 99% Invisible. New episodes will be coming to you in the 99PI feed on Tuesdays and Fridays, wherever you get your podcasts. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is our digital director. The rest of the 99PI team includes Chris Barube, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Gabriela Gladney, Jacob Maldonado Medina, and Nina Potuck.
好朋友凯西·科尔曼（Casey Coleman）、苏珊·萨凯什（Susan Sakesh）和莱伊沃恩（Leivon），他们在我去路易斯安那州旅行期间接待并包容了我。《不属于这里》是99%隐形（99% Invisible）推出的六集系列节目。新节目将会在每周二和周五的99PI订阅源中更新，无论你在哪里收听播客。凯西·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ad（Kurt Kolstad）是我们的数字总监。99PI团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Barube）、维维安·莱（Vivian Ley）、拉沙·马多恩（Lasha Madon）、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Gabriela Gladney）、雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonado Medina）和妮娜·波图克（Nina Potuck）。
The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are a part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family. You can find 99% Invisible on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that and every episode of 99PI and Not Built For This at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99%隐形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们新的Discord服务器上找到99%隐形。在99PI.org上可以找到指向该服务器以及99PI和《不属于这里》每一期节目的链接。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。